this is your first tour in canada
since 2013. so like what the hell was
the holdup because canada loves you it
wasn't a canada thing i think it's a
world thing i just thought let's keep
adding countries because i'm trying to
make connections you can't go deaf
ah cake for me too please
what would you say that canadian fans
can expect from the wonder bar tour i've
worked out how the universe works i
think and i could be wrong but i could
be right does it really matter do tigers
care if we're straight games
and then
they don't care they're just tigers we
don't care about whether they are why
are we getting so head-up about this
who is janine with the weather
thank you it'll be sunny forever thanks
junior i will say that you are a queer
icon within the lgbtq plus community and
that's truly so important so what does
it mean for you to be that person who is
living authentically and just really
sharing the message of love and hope and
just owning who you are
i think it's wonderful i never thought
it could get to this place
it hurt his ring tell something was
going on
the people looked okay
you want me to find a piece of a very
old puzzle
like a runic variation smart people
it's upside down what did you love about
being part of dan brown's last symbol
working with the guys in the lost symbol
and dan brown it's been a wonderful time
i love the quality of the sets i was
working on the writers the intelligence
the energy great crews in canada here in
toronto